Nous allons, j'avais beaucoup d'hésitation à un moment sur qu'est-ce que faire, surtout après la conférence, je me demandais est-ce que je prends ce texte ou je vais sur un autre.
Et après j'ai été en paix quand j'ai vu les grêlons qui sont tombés hier. Je me suis dit que c'est le bon moment. C'est toujours bien de prêcher Ezekiel après ces moments.
Bon, plus sérieusement, nous allons poursuivre et je vais d'abord profiter un peu pour résumer rapidement par rapport à tout ce que nous avons aussi pu voir avant.
Aujourd'hui, nous allons nous focaliser essentiellement sur les versets 11 à 14 et je pense même surtout le verset 11 parce que je pense aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de choses que le Seigneur peut nous dire au travers de ça.
Donc, Ezekiel, je fais un rappel, le peuple d'Israël à un moment va être envahi, va être attaqué par plusieurs nations et à la chute de l'Empire assyrien, l'Empire babylonien va se lever et les Babyloniens vont attaquer Jérusalem.
Il va avoir un premier siège et à l'issue de ce premier siège, donc c'était à peu près en 605 avant Jésus-Christ, ils vont emporter une partie de l'élite et donc Daniel fait partie de ces personnes qui vont être déportées à Babylone.
Huit ans plus tard, là encore, Babylone va poser un siège sur Jérusalem et là, il va à peu près avoir 10 000 Juifs qui vont être déportés et Ezekiel fait partie de ces 10 000 Juifs qui vont être déportés à Babylone.
Et pendant que Ezekiel est à Babylone, qu'il est découragé par cette situation parce que dans les paroles qu'ils avaient reçues du Seigneur, Dieu leur avait promis Israël, la terre promise, Canaan comme la terre promise,
ils avaient du mal à pouvoir imaginer que Dieu puisse les déraciner de là, puisse les enlever de là.
Et donc pendant qu'Ezekiel était à Babylone, Dieu va se révéler à lui au travers d'une apparition divine et Dieu va lui confier une mission.
Dieu lui confie la mission, c'est d'annoncer que les destructions dont ils étaient l'objet, les déportations successives dont ils étaient l'objet étaient les conséquences de la punition d'un peuple qui avait été rebelle à Dieu.
Et ce qu'il y a lorsque Dieu lève Ezekiel, c'est que c'est un peuple qui, malgré cette punition, refusait de se repentir, même dans l'exil.
Ils n'arrivaient pas à reconnaître leur faute.
Et donc si vous avez l'occasion, et j'espère, de lire Ezekiel, si vous avez déjà lu Ezekiel ou vous ne l'avez pas encore fait, je vous encourage à le faire.
Nous voyons au moment que dans Ezekiel, il y a trois parties. Il y a le jugement à venir de Jérusalem que Dieu donne à Ezekiel et actuellement nous sommes dans cette partie.
Il y a le jugement des nations à venir et il y a aussi l'annonce de la restauration à venir d'Israël.
D'abord une restauration physique, c'est-à-dire que Dieu les a déportés, Dieu annonce la destruction de Jérusalem, mais Dieu promet un jour qu'il va tout restaurer, il va les ramener à Jérusalem.
Et il annonce aussi un peu, dans ce sens aussi, il annonce la venue du Messie.
Et dans ce que nous avions vu dernièrement, je résume rapidement sur les quatre derniers chapitres, dans cette première partie qui décrit le jugement de Jérusalem,
nous avons vu qu'il y avait trois signes qui déterminaient ce jugement, c'est-à-dire que Dieu utilise Ezekiel pour montrer au peuple, au travers de trois signes évidents, le jugement à venir.
Donc le peuple qui était déporté à Jérusalem, non seulement il refusait de se repentir, mais il avait aussi l'intime conviction qu'ils allaient retourner à Jérusalem directement.
Ils étaient sûrs que Dieu allait faire quelque chose et qu'il allait les ramener à Jérusalem, donc sans même se repentir.
Ils n'arrivaient pas à voir en quoi ils avaient péché.
Mais Dieu utilise Ezekiel et donc à un moment, Dieu va lui faire construire une sorte de maquette avec des casseroles et plein d'autres objets pour illustrer le siège final de Jérusalem.
Ensuite, Dieu va lui demander de se coucher sur un côté droit à un moment, un côté gauche, pour illustrer, pour symboliser les jugements des deux royaumes.
Parce qu'à un moment, Israël était un seul royaume. Il y a eu une division à la mort de Salomon.
À la mort de Salomon, son fils n'a pas su conserver. À un moment, le royaume a été divisé en deux.
Le royaume d'Israël au nord et le royaume de Juda au sud.
Et donc Dieu va, au travers des différentes positions d'Ezekiel,
Dieu est en train de symboliser le jugement de ces deux royaumes selon le nombre d'années de leurs iniquités.
Et donc dans ce cas, par exemple, le royaume du nord avait déjà été jugé.
Il avait déjà été détruit par l'Empire assyrien.
Et donc il ne restait que le royaume du sud, le royaume de Juda,
qui était composé de deux tribus et des restes du royaume du nord qui les avait réunis.
Dans ce chapitre que nous venons de lire,
nous avons le troisième signe de jugement, c'était le rasoir.
Donc c'est un rasoir de barbier.
Et donc avec ce rasoir de barbier,
Dieu demande à Ézéchiel de se raser la barbe, de se raser la tête.
Et normalement, les sacrificateurs ne le faisaient pas.
C'était normalement, ils ne le faisaient pas.
Et donc c'était un signe fort.
C'est-à-dire que Dieu était en train d'envoyer un signe fort.
Quand le peuple allait voir Ézéchiel en train de se raser,
ils allaient comprendre, Dieu voulait envoyer un message.
Et donc le message au travers de ce rasage,
c'était pour décrire la profonde humiliation que les judéens allaient vivre quelques temps plus tard.
Donc ce que nous avons lu, certains allaient être châtiés dans le feu,
donc par la peste, par la famine.
D'autres allaient être passés au fil de l'épée par l'ennemi.
Et d'autres enfin seraient dispersés et ils allaient être poursuivis jusqu'au bout.
Et même ceux qui allaient être dispersés et poursuivis jusqu'au bout,
le Seigneur dit même à un moment que même dans ce reste,
de ceux qui allaient fuir, ils allaient encore être poursuivis.
Il n'y avait qu'un reste qui allait survivre et traverser de nouvelles épreuves.
Et toutes ces choses que je suis en train de vous dire se sont accomplies de façon littérale.
Si vous lisez par exemple Jérémie 41, chapitres 41 à 44,
vous allez retrouver tout ce que je suis en train de vous dire.
Et donc, à partir du verset 5 que nous avions vu la dernière fois,
Dieu rentre dans quelques détails qui vont décrire pourquoi ce jugement.
Et donc, nous lisons un moment que nous avons lu tout à l'heure,
Jérusalem qui était la perle des nations s'était détournée du but que Dieu lui avait donné.
C'est-à-dire que quand Dieu s'inquiète un peuple,
c'est-à-dire Israël est esclave en Égypte,
Dieu les sauve de cet esclavage,
c'est-à-dire qu'il en fait son peuple.
Il en fait son peuple.
Donc, c'était une alliance,
c'était quelque chose qui ne pouvait pas être révoqué normalement.
Il en fait son peuple.
Et il en fait son peuple afin de pouvoir afficher sa gloire.
C'est-à-dire qu'il en fait son peuple,
il ordonne ses statuts, ses lois, ses commandements,
et Israël devait les appliquer
et pouvoir être un témoignage pour les nations païennes autour.
Mais Israël a échoué dans ce but.
Au lieu d'être un témoin pour les nations païennes,
Israël est tombé dans les pratiques idolâtres.
Ils ont imité les pratiques de ces nations.
Ils ont même dépassé les pratiques de ces nations.
Et quand on parle même de dépasser,
c'est parce qu'ils avaient la connaissance.
Ils savaient ce qu'ils devaient faire.
Ils avaient des privilèges spirituels
que Dieu leur avait donnés pendant des siècles.
Ils ont goûté.
Et vous voyez même que ce qui les étonne,
c'est de voir la fidélité de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire que malgré le fait qu'ils avaient péché plusieurs fois,
la patience de Dieu n'était jamais arrivée à sa limite.
Et chaque fois, quand ils avaient eu besoin,
si vous lisez le livre des juges,
Israël pêchait, c'est le schéma.
Si on fait un cycle, Israël pêche,
il y a une nation qui va les asservir.
Dieu envoie un juge.
Israël est délivré.
On vit un peu dans la paix.
Après, Israël pêche.
On fait le même cycle.
Et donc, ils étaient sûrs à un moment,
ils avaient commencé à prendre cette grâce de Dieu pour acquise.
Et ils pensaient à un moment que de toute façon,
Dieu les délivrait toujours.
On voit l'exemple avec Samson, par exemple,
qui va pécher et qui se dit à un moment,
c'est ce qui symbolise un peu cette chose-là.
Donc, malgré la connaissance,
malgré les privilèges qu'Israël avait,
malgré les oracles qui leur avaient été confiés,
comme la parole de Dieu le dit à un moment,
ils avaient quand même choisi d'aller vers les pratiques.
idolâtres.
Et même ce qui est grave à un moment,
c'est que même quand Dieu leur a donné,
il y a même des rois,
Dieu leur a donné la victoire sur l'ennemi.
Ils ont vaincu les dieux de ces ennemis.
Mais ce qu'ils vont faire,
c'est qu'ils vont prendre ces dieux qu'ils ont vaincus
pour les amener dans le temple et les adorer.
Il y avait quelque chose qui n'avait pas de sens là-dessus.
Et donc, à un moment,
Dieu prend en considération la connaissance qu'Israël avait,
l'éclairage qu'ils avaient,
pour souligner le caractère exceptionnel de ce jugement.
Donc, ce qui arrivait,
et ce qui était étonnant pour Israël,
c'est que c'est un jugement,
cette sorte de jugement ne devait arriver qu'aux nations
qui ne servaient pas Dieu.
Mais là, ce jugement arrivait sur Israël.
Et donc, on a lu ces châtiments,
du verset 8 à 10,
ce sont des châtiments qui sont très difficiles.
On nous parle un moment
qu'il va y avoir des brisements dans les familles,
il va y avoir des pères qui vont...
Donc là, on parle d'une certaine violence.
Mais dans certains cas,
la Bible nous parle même de mères
qui, ayant accouché l'enfant,
vont sacrifier leur enfant,
vont le manger pour être sauvés de la famine.
Donc, c'est des choses qu'Israël n'avait jamais vécues.
Mais Dieu permet qu'ils le vivent.
Pour souligner,
le caractère exceptionnel du jugement,
parce qu'Israël, la patience de Dieu était arrivée à sa limite,
et Dieu voulait apprendre quelque chose à Israël.
Le jugement qu'ils étaient en train de vivre,
c'est un jugement qui avait été annoncé par Moïse
plusieurs siècles avant.
Si vous lisez Deutéronome Lévitique,
vous allez voir au moment que Moïse avait annoncé
tous ces châtiments,
si Israël se détournait à un moment de Dieu.
Et ils l'ont vécu.
Et en lisant le livre des Lamentations,
vous allez voir littéralement
que toutes ces choses se sont accomplies.
Mais aujourd'hui, sur la partie du texte
sur lequel nous allons méditer,
nous allons voir,
et l'insistance,
s'il est entre les versets 11 et 13,
c'est de voir comment Dieu insiste
au travers des propos d'Ézéchiel
pour inscrire dans la conscience du peuple d'Israël.
Vous voyez, le verset 11,
il va dire à un moment,
« C'est pourquoi je suis vivant,
dit le Seigneur l'Éternel,
parce que tu as souillé mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles et toutes tes abominations.
Moi aussi, je retirerai mon œil,
et mon œil sera sans pitié.
Moi aussi, je n'aurai point de miséricorde. »
Verset 13,
« J'assouvirai ainsi ma colère,
je ferai reposer ma fureur sur eux,
je me donnerai satisfaction.
Et ils sauront que moi, l'Éternel,
j'ai parlé dans ma colère
en répondant sur eux ma fureur. »
Donc, ce sont des propos que Dieu tenait plutôt
contre les nations qui se levaient contre Israël
que plutôt contre Israël.
Mais là, Dieu tient ses propos
pour marquer dans la conscience d'Israël
qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à voir en quoi ils avaient péché
la profonde haine que Dieu éprouvait
par rapport à l'idolâtrie d'Israël,
par rapport à l'apostasie d'Israël.
Donc, quand on parle d'idolâtrie,
c'était le fait de choisir d'adorer
des idoles, d'adorer d'autres faux dieux
qui n'étaient même pas des dieux,
c'était des idoles de bois, de pierre et autres
à la place de Dieu.
Et c'était le fait de renier.
L'apostasie, c'est dans ce principe
de renier ce en quoi on croit.
Donc, à un moment, ils ont choisi
de renier l'Éternel.
Et à cause de ça, Dieu dit à un moment
que sa profonde haine va s'exercer,
sa fureur va s'exercer sur Israël.
Mais comment, et c'est ça que nous allons voir ce matin,
comment Dieu est en train de manifester cette haine.
Tout d'abord, il le rappelle lorsque nous lisons
le début du verset 11.
Il dit, c'est pourquoi je suis vivant.
La dernière fois, lors de la dernière prédication
sur ces précédents versets
que nous avions médité,
nous avions vu que la colère de Dieu
contre toute impiété des hommes
sera toujours pure et sera toujours justifiée.
Nous avions insisté pour rappeler un moment
que souvent, le problème de l'être humain,
c'est que nous cherchons à comprendre Dieu
à partir de notre propre vision,
de notre propre façon de voir le monde.
Et donc, quand nous voyons un Dieu en colère,
nous le voyons comme nous,
nous manifestons la colère envers nos semblables.
Quand nous voyons un Dieu,
quand nous voyons un Dieu
qui manque de pardon,
c'est parce que nous appliquons notre façon à nous
de manquer de pardon.
Et donc,
à cause de notre nature compue,
et même à cause de sa nature compue de façon générale,
l'homme ne se pose jamais de questions en général
sur les causes qui conduisent au jugement de Dieu.
Vous allez remarquer qu'on ne dit jamais,
mais pourquoi ce jugement est arrivé ?
Pourquoi ces choses arrivent ?
On va plutôt dire,
mais si Dieu est bon,
pourquoi ces choses arrivent ?
Si ce Dieu est si bon,
Mais on ne réfléchit pas en disant,
mais pourquoi ces choses arrivent ?
Pourquoi Dieu permet que ces choses arrivent ?
Et donc,
on va généralement plutôt se poser des questions,
on ne va pas se poser des questions
sur les causes qui conduisent au jugement,
mais on va plutôt se poser des questions
sur les conséquences du jugement.
Au moment où nous vivons le jugement,
nous allons trouver que Dieu est injuste.
On va trouver que Dieu n'est pas bon.
Et ce dont nous avons besoin,
c'est que nous devons toujours comprendre,
si nous voulons être honnêtes,
si nous voulons être honnêtes et comprendre
ce que Dieu nous dit
à propos de l'état du monde,
il faut que nous repartions à ce que dit la Bible.
Et ce que la Bible nous dit à un moment,
c'est que Dieu avait créé un monde parfait,
un monde qui n'était pas touché
par la corruption du péché,
avec Adam et Ève.
Mais à un moment,
Adam et Ève sont sortis des limites
que Dieu leur avait données,
de la liberté que Dieu leur avait données.
Ils ont péché par orgueil.
Et lorsqu'ils ont péché,
ils ont eu à laisser entrer le péché dans le monde.
Et la corruption du monde a entraîné
tout ce que nous pouvons voir autour de nous.
Une nature qui est maintenant rebelle à l'homme,
cette nature qui était soumise à Adam et Ève,
est maintenant rebelle.
Vous avez le bon exemple.
Ce matin, on parlait avec notre sœur Esther
qui est revenue,
elle nous parlait des moustiques.
Je pense qu'à un moment,
une des choses les plus évidentes
de comprendre la rébellion de la création,
c'est quand vous allez vivre des moustiques
en Asie ou en Afrique.
Nous comprenons comment la nature s'est révélée
et à cause de toutes ces choses,
et même pour nous, êtres humains,
comment maintenant nous sommes remplis
de désirs qui vont à l'encontre
de ce que Dieu attend.
Et donc, quand nous devons chaque fois
comprendre la colère de Dieu,
même lorsque nous lisons des passages
comme ceci dans Ézéchiel,
nous devons toujours comprendre
que la colère de Dieu,
au contraire de celle des hommes,
est toujours sainte,
elle est toujours justifiée.
Notre frère Nathanaël nous a lu
rappeler cet épisode,
lorsque le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
va même rappeler un moment,
il va nettoyer le temple,
il va leur rappeler,
vous avez fait de ce temple
une caverne de voleurs.
Vous voyez là, manifestait de la colère,
mais c'était une colère sainte.
C'est une colère qui était justifiée
par rapport à ce qu'il était en train de voir,
qui était fait contre la parole de Dieu.
Dieu ne supporte pas le péché.
Il faut que ça nous l'acceptions,
que nous le comprenions.
Dieu ne peut pas supporter le péché
et nous devons comprendre
que dans ce principe
de ce que nous sommes en train de dire,
le péché doit alors être vu
comme le fait d'aller contre
ce que Dieu a établi
comme chose naturelle,
comme loi naturelle pour nous.
Lorsque nous sommes en train
d'aller contre ça,
nous sommes en train de pécher.
C'est important,
je veux toujours lire,
parce que c'est un passage
qui parle tellement au sujet
de cette incompréhension de la création
vis-à-vis de ce que Dieu a fait,
vis-à-vis de la façon dont nous nous comportons
maintenant étant soumis au péché.
Mais Paul rappelle un moment,
il dit un moment,
la colère de Dieu,
donc il parle de cette colère
qui est sainte et justifiée.
C'était le cas d'Israël,
c'est le cas même pour les païens,
mais ce que Dieu voulait mettre
en phase avec Israël
lorsqu'il a affiché ses lois
et ses commandements,
c'est que ces choses
deviennent plus évidentes,
c'est que même ces païens
qui avaient ces lois naturelles de Dieu
puissent comprendre à un moment
que c'était le Dieu d'Israël
était le Dieu qui avait emmené ces choses.
Et Paul va dire,
en effet,
les perfections invisibles de Dieu,
sa puissance éternelle
et sa divinité
se voient comme à l'œil
depuis la création du monde
quand on les considère
dans ses ouvrages.
Ils sont donc inexcusables
puisque ayant connu Dieu,
ils ne l'ont point glorifié comme Dieu
et ne lui ont point rendu grâce.
Mais ils se sont égarés
dans leurs pensées
et leur cœur sans intelligence
a été plongé dans les ténèbres.
Se vantant d'être sages,
ils sont devenus fous.
Et ils ont changé la gloire
du Dieu incorruptible en images
représentant l'homme corruptible,
des oiseaux,
des quadrupèdes
et des reptiles.
Ce que Paul est en train de dire
de sa génération,
c'est la même chose
qu'Ézéchiel pouvait dire
de sa génération.
C'était exactement la même chose.
Et souvent,
nous avons tendance à croire
que l'homme s'est amélioré
avec le temps,
par rapport à nos lois.
L'homme ne s'est pas amélioré.
Le cœur de l'homme est le même.
Le problème de l'homme
reste toujours le même.
Le péché traverse les siècles.
Et même si nous pouvons être sophistiqués,
la seule différence
entre quelqu'un en Amazonie,
dans la forêt,
et un pécheur parisien,
c'est le pécheur parisien
qui aura une cravate.
Il sera un peu plus éduqué,
mais il reste un pécheur.
Donc, le problème de l'homme,
et quand nous lisons
ce passage de Romain,
le problème de l'homme
ne sera donc jamais
de ne pas savoir
ce qu'il aurait dû faire.
Mais ce sera plutôt
de ne pas vouloir le faire.
Et donc,
lorsque Dieu dit à un moment,
au verset 11,
c'est pourquoi je suis vivant,
c'est très important.
Les hommes peuvent refuser
de le croire,
les hommes peuvent l'oublier,
mais Dieu est vivant.
La formule qui est employée
au verset 11,
c'est un serment solennel
qui est en train
de confirmer l'existence
et l'accomplissement
de la parole
ou de la prophétie
qui est dite.
Il dit,
je suis vivant,
c'est pourquoi je suis vivant.
Quand Dieu est en train
de dire ça,
il est en train de dire
à un moment
que c'est irrévocable,
c'est quelque chose
qu'il va accomplir.
Il va l'accomplir
parce que même si
nous n'arrivons pas
à accepter,
même si nous avons choisi
d'aller dans une autre voie,
lorsque ces jugements,
ces décrets s'accomplissent,
ils s'accomplissent
parce qu'il est vivant.
Et une des façons
par lesquelles
Dieu rappelle à l'humanité
qu'il est vivant,
c'est de manifester
ses jugements
quand son infinie patience
est arrivé à son terme.
Notre Dieu est bon.
Notre Dieu est juste.
Le livre d'Ézéchiel
était très difficile
pour moi au début
pendant plusieurs années,
jusqu'à ce que je me mette
à préparer ces prédications.
Et j'ai réalisé un moment
que même lorsque Dieu
était en train d'exercer
sa colère
sur le peuple d'Israël,
parce que le livre d'Ézéchiel
peut être très difficile
à un moment,
je remarquais
qu'en fait Dieu
était en train
de manifester
aussi sa miséricorde.
Pendant des siècles,
Dieu aurait pu juger Israël.
Il ne les a pas jugés.
Sa patience
a été manifestée
pendant plusieurs siècles.
Pendant plusieurs siècles
de péché
jusqu'à ce que sa patience
arrive à son terme.
Jusqu'à ce que Dieu décide
que la terre
sur laquelle ils étaient
et où ils ne voulaient pas
donner de repos
à cette terre,
Dieu décide
que cette terre
va se reposer.
Et il a permis
que lorsque cette terre
était reposée,
c'est là où il permet
que les rois païens
qui retenaient
les Israéliens,
les Israélites
en déportation,
leur permettent
de revenir
sur cette terre.
Lorsque nous avions,
sur la dernière prédication
qu'on avait abordé,
ça,
je me souviens
que le texte
d'introduction
de la prédication
du culte
était aussi lié à ça.
Esaïe 26,
si vous vous souvenez,
du verset 7
au verset 10,
il dit
« Le chemin du juste
est la droiture.
Toi qui es juste,
tu as plani
le sentier du juste.
Aussi nous t'attendons
au éternel
sur la voie
de tes jugements. »
Nous qui sommes chrétiens,
nous devons toujours
comprendre
que les jugements
de Dieu sont justes.
Si tu es chrétien
aujourd'hui
et que tu as souvent
du mal encore
à comprendre,
à pouvoir voir
et à souvent t'interroger
en te disant
« Maman,
mais Dieu,
pourquoi tu permets cela ? »
Prie pour que le Saint-Esprit
éclaire davantage ton cœur.
Lorsque nous avons
la compréhension
de ces vérités,
nous verrons toujours,
nous allons toujours
nous attendre
à l'éternel
sur la voie
de ces jugements.
Notre âme soupire
après ton nom
et après ton souvenir.
Verset 9
« Mon âme te désire
pendant la nuit
et mon esprit
te cherche au-dedans
de moi.
Car lorsque tes jugements
s'exercent sur la terre,
les habitants du monde
apprennent la justice.
S'il en fait grâce
aux méchants,
il n'apprend pas la justice,
il se livre au mal
dans le pays
de la droiture
et il n'a point égard
à la majesté de Dieu. »
Voilà pourquoi
Dieu permet
les jugements.
Dieu juge
un moment,
Dieu permet
que ces jugements
s'exercent
pour réfréner
la méchanceté
du cœur humain.
Et quand Dieu
permet que ces jugements
s'exercent,
ces corrections
s'exercent sur nous
et c'était le cas
pour Israël,
vous voyez,
à un moment,
Dieu permet
le jugement
sur Israël
mais au contraire
d'autres nations
qui ont été détruites
et qui n'ont pas pu
se relever de ça,
Dieu relève Israël.
Dieu va les restaurer,
il va les ramener
sur leur terre.
Il va continuer
à accomplir
ce qu'il avait prévu
parfaitement.
Et donc,
nous ne devons pas
voir la correction
de Dieu
comme étant
un manque d'amour.
Nous devons voir
la correction de Dieu
comme étant une grâce
pour corriger
notre cœur.
Les jugements
de Dieu
permettent de corriger
la méchanceté
du cœur humain
et nous montrer
notre besoin
d'un salut.
C'était aussi,
c'est la grande leçon,
en continuant
à parcourir
Israël,
nous allons voir
la grande leçon
que Dieu aussi
donnait à Israël.
Lorsqu'il est place
comme une nation
témoin
et qu'Israël
n'arrive pas
à respecter
les lois,
les standards de Dieu,
c'était aussi
pour leur montrer
le besoin
d'un sauveur.
Israël était
en train de préparer
la venue du Messie.
Le problème
d'Israël,
c'est qu'ils ont cru
à un moment
qu'ils n'avaient pas
besoin d'atteindre
le Messie
et qu'ils pouvaient
obéir à cette loi
d'eux-mêmes.
Et lorsque ce jugement
arrive,
Dieu est en train
de leur montrer
qu'ils ne peuvent pas
obéir à cette loi
d'eux-mêmes.
Le deuxième point
qui nous montre
où Dieu est en train
de manifester,
où il voulait ancrer
dans la conscience
du peuple
et d'Israël
sa haine
de cette idolâtrie
et de cette apostasie,
il le dit
dans la suite
du verset 11.
Donc, il dit
c'est pourquoi
je suis vivant.
Donc, il rappelle
un moment
que ces jugements
arrivent
parce que même
si Israël
agit
comme s'ils
ignoraient
qu'il existait,
il le leur rappelle.
Le deuxième point,
il dit
c'est pourquoi
je suis vivant
dit le Seigneur
l'Éternel
parce que tu as
souillé mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles
et toutes tes abominations.
La parole de Dieu
nous rappelle
et c'est pour ça
que j'étais
reconnaissant aussi
à Dieu
dans l'introduction
dans les chants
et même
dans le texte
des offrandes
qui nous rappelait
à un moment
que la présence
de Dieu
pour nous
est aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus
évidente
n'est pas
symbolisée
par un bâtiment
Dieu
est
dans le corps
de Christ
l'ensemble
des croyants
forment
le corps
de Christ
et Dieu
est dans
ce corps.
La parole
de Dieu
nous le montre
dans plusieurs
aspects
que Dieu
nous rappelle
à un moment
que les cieux
des cieux
ne peuvent
le contenir
et qu'il
n'habite pas
dans un temple
fait de mains
d'hommes.
Mais au moment
où il va
acquérir Israël
lorsqu'il va
faire d'Israël
son peuple
une des choses
qu'il y a
c'est qu'il va
toujours symboliser
sa présence
au milieu d'eux.
Le premier aspect
où il symbolise
la présence
à un moment
ce sera
la tente
du tabernacle.
Donc pendant
qu'Israël
est sauvé
de l'esclavage
en Égypte
Dieu les conduit
dans le désert
pour les amener
à Canaan
et pendant
qu'ils sont
dans le désert
il y aura
selon les instructions
qu'il donne à Moïse
Moïse va monter
la tente
du tabernacle
où il y avait
des éléments
pour l'adoration
de Dieu
et c'est
dans cette
tente
du tabernacle
symboliser
la présence
de Dieu
au milieu
d'Israël
et d'ailleurs
la tente
était même
au centre
du camp
c'est-à-dire
les tribus
étaient organisées
tout autour
il y avait
la tente
du tabernacle
au centre
qui symbolisait
la présence
de Dieu
au milieu
de son peuple
par la suite
il y a eu
le temple
qui a été
construit
par le roi
Salomon
et qui est
devenu aussi
ce symbole
de la présence
de Dieu
donc Dieu
on va dire
Dieu quitte
la tente
du tabernacle
Dieu
met maintenant
sa présence
dans le temple
mais aujourd'hui
pour nous
cette conscience
par rapport
à ce temple
c'est de voir
un moment
qu'aujourd'hui
comme on a dit
nous ne sommes plus
attachés
à des éléments
matériels
et c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui
que si certains
sont encore
en train
d'espérer
aujourd'hui
il y a des personnes
qui attendent encore
la reconstruction
du temple
à Jérusalem
pour voir la présence
de Dieu
ce sont des choses
qui sont dépassées
qui sont obsolètes
parce qu'au moment
où Jésus Christ
a tout accompli
à la croix
ce qu'il y a
c'est que
c'est ce passage
que nous avons lu
dans Hébreu
il est rentré
dans un temple
qui n'est pas fait
de main d'homme
et qui est le temple
parfait
mais aujourd'hui
par l'œuvre de Christ
notre corps
le corps de chaque
croyant
est devenu
le temple
de Dieu
et lorsque Dieu
parle
du rappel
par rapport
au sanctuaire
le problème
d'Israël
c'est qu'ils avaient
méprisé
la présence
de Dieu
au milieu d'eux
il y a un aspect
qui était
c'est un aspect
qui est important
aussi
qui est encore revenu
ils avaient d'abord
souillé
le sanctuaire
a d'abord été souillé
par rapport
à l'état
de leur cœur
c'est à dire
avec le fait déjà
de venir avec
des cœurs souillés
il était impossible
qu'ils puissent
offrir
des sacrifices
qui sont en train
d'honorer Dieu
c'est ce que Dieu
met en emphase
avec le passage
d'Ézéchiel
il montre à un moment
que dans la façon
dont ils avaient souillé
c'est que même
en étant conscient
de leur péché
ils choisissaient
de venir
dans la présence
de Dieu
avec leur péché
Ézéchiel 14
au verset 2
Dieu va reprocher
à un moment
il y a les anciens
d'Israël
qui vont venir
pour écouter
Ézéchiel
pour le flatter
en quelque sorte
et Dieu va lui dire
un moment
regarde
regarde ces hommes
ils viennent devant toi
ils portent leurs idoles
dans leur cœur
donc ils avaient d'abord
souillé
il était impossible
ils avaient déjà souillé
le sanctuaire de Dieu
par déjà
leur cœur
qui était rempli
d'idoles
et c'est une vérité
que l'état
de notre cœur
va grandement déterminer
notre façon
d'adorer
ils ont souillé
le sanctuaire
et voilà ce que
Jérémie va dire
à ce sujet
Jérémie au chapitre 7
du verset 8 à 11
il va dire
mais voici
vous vous livrez
à des espérances
trompeuses
qui ne servent à rien
quoi ?
dérober
tuer
commettre des adultères
jurer faussement
offrir de l'encens
à bal
aller après
d'autres dieux
que vous ne connaissez pas
puis
vous venez
vous présenter
devant moi
dans cette maison
sur laquelle
mon nom
est invoqué
et vous dites
nous sommes délivrés
l'aspect d'Israël
il dit
et c'est afin
de commettre
toutes ces abominations
est-elle
donc il parle
et notre frère
Nathaniel a pris
ce passage aussi
en lien
est-elle à vos yeux
une caverne de voleurs
cette maison
sur laquelle
mon nom est invoqué
je le vois
moi-même
dit l'éternel
le problème d'Israël
pour beaucoup
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
cherché à connaître Dieu
là encore
ce lien de Romain
ils n'ont pas cherché
à connaître Dieu
ils n'ont pas voulu
connaître ce que
Dieu attendait d'eux
et ils se sont permis
déjà
avec le fait
de ne pas vouloir
connaître Dieu
et de porter leurs idoles
ils se sont permis
d'apporter des idoles
et des pratiques idolâtres
que Dieu réprouvait
dans le sanctuaire
et voilà pourquoi
Dieu parle à un moment
vous avez souillé
mon sanctuaire
à un moment
Dieu va même donner
des visions à Ézéchiel
où il le transporte
en esprit
jusqu'à Jérusalem
et que Ézéchiel
va voir que même
au milieu
de cette punition
ils sont en train
de continuer
à adorer de faux dieux
même au milieu
de cette punition
où des prophètes
comme Jérémie
sont en train
de leur pointer
leurs péchés
et de les appeler
à la repentance
ils étaient en train
d'installer des idoles
dans le temple
donc ils avaient souillé
le sanctuaire de Dieu
alors que Dieu
avait été très clair
sur la façon
dont le culte
à son égard
devait être administré
mais ils avaient décidé
de redéfinir
ce que devait être
le culte rendu
à l'éternel
ils avaient décidé
de ne pas
venir avec des cœurs
purifiés
devant la présence
de Dieu
ils avaient choisi
de venir avec des cœurs
partagés
ils avaient ce calcul
de se dire
à un moment
nous pouvons suivre
les penchants
de notre cœur
et nous pouvons
espérer la délivrance
de Dieu
c'est ce que Jérémie
nous dit à un moment
vous venez vous présenter
devant moi
dans cette maison
sous laquelle mon nom
est invoqué
et vous dites
nous sommes délivrés
aujourd'hui
comme je vous ai dit
il y avait le passage
de Romain
qui nous parle
de la génération
de Paul
il y a
Ézéchiel
qui nous parle
de sa génération
mais ce que nous lisons
est aussi valable
pour notre génération
aujourd'hui encore
beaucoup de personnes
viennent
soi-disant
pour chercher
le Seigneur
mais avec des cœurs
qui sont remplis
d'idolâtrie
avec des cœurs
qui sont partagés
ce sont des personnes
qui n'ont pas
ce désir
de chercher Dieu
qui n'ont pas
ce désir
de connaître
qu'est-ce que Dieu
attend d'eux
mais qui ont plutôt
le désir
de voir Dieu
selon leurs envies
ce sont des personnes
qui ont le désir
de redéfinir
ce que doit être
une église
notre frère Loïc
tout à l'heure
nous a dit
à un moment
que lorsque nous
nous allons donner
nous n'allons pas donner
parce que le pasteur
nous a dit
nous n'allons pas donner
parce que nous avons
une pression quelconque
nous allons donner
parce que nous connaissons
les principes
qui sont dans ce livre
et en fonction
des principes
qui sont dans ce livre
que nous appliquons
voilà pourquoi
nous faisons un don
à l'éternel
mais pour beaucoup
aujourd'hui
pour définir
une église
et c'était le cas
des hébreux
des juifs
autant des équels
ils avaient décidé
de définir
le culte de l'éternel
selon leurs envies
et aujourd'hui
pour beaucoup
ils vont définir
l'église
en fonction des idoles
qu'ils portent
dans leur cœur
je suis
je suis fils de pasteur
et je sais
à un moment
que quand tu es
fils de pasteur
même souvent
une des mauvaises choses
c'est souvent
d'attendre
même souvent
un pasteur
peut avoir des enfants
qui ne sont pas encore convertis
mais on va attendre
que les enfants du pasteur
vivent comme s'ils étaient convertis
et souvent
vous avez des pressions
vous avez beaucoup de choses
et j'ai par exemple
vu beaucoup de
de personnes
qui ont
qui ont créé
des mouvements d'église
aujourd'hui
qui sont très influents
mais qui ont créé
ces mouvements d'église
à partir des blessures
qu'ils ont eues
en étant fils de pasteur
à cause des blessures
qu'ils ont eues
ils se sont dit
à un moment
je ne vais pas chercher
à
à conduire
une église
selon ce que la parole
de Dieu dit
parce que ça peut être dépassé
mais je vais la construire
en fonction des blessures
que j'ai eues
et quand
vous voyez souvent
cet aspect
d'église
qui vont présenter
un Dieu qui est cool
un Dieu qui ne juge pas
et donc souvent
je me demande
qu'est-ce qu'ils font
des équels
mais souvent
dans ce sens
ils vont dire
le Dieu du Nouveau Testament
ne juge pas
le Dieu dont l'ancien
était méchant
et jugé
c'est le même Dieu
il n'a pas changé
et donc
quand ils vont se permettre
de dire un moment
il faut que Dieu soit cool
il faut présenter un Dieu
qui soit cool
un Dieu qui ne te juge pas
un Dieu qui t'aime juste
pour ce que tu es
Dieu nous aime
malgré ce que nous sommes
mais Dieu ne nous laisse pas
dans l'état
dans lequel nous sommes
mais c'est
cet évangile
c'est un évangile
qui dit à un moment
reste comme tu es
et essaye de trouver
ce qui va dans ta convenance
dans la parole
essaye de trouver dans la parole
ce qui va convenir à ta vie
ça ce sont des pratiques idolâtres
ça c'est
c'est de porter
des idoles dans son coeur
de venir dans la présence de Dieu
et de souiller le sanctuaire
on va souiller le sanctuaire
par des blessures
et à cause des blessures
de la vie qu'on a eue
on va vouloir redéfinir
la parole de Dieu
parce qu'on a eu un divorce
parce qu'on a eu
telle ou telle situation
on ne va pas aller
selon les principes
qui sont dits dans la Bible
on va aller par rapport
à notre situation à nous
et par rapport
à notre envie de redéfinir
certains vont redéfinir l'église
selon leurs envies charnelles
où on va justifier
certaines choses
parce que de toute façon
Dieu est amour
ou on va justifier
d'autres choses
parce qu'avec le poids
de la culture
du légalisme
ou bien un moment
du progressisme
il y a certains
qui vont
faire une église
non pas
ils vont redéfinir l'église
selon la culture
et donc à un moment
on va avoir du mal
parce qu'il ne faut pas
choquer les gens
dans une génération
qui est très instruite
la question se pose quand même
qui est censée être
très instruite
on va dire à un moment
qu'il ne faut pas parler
de six jours littéraux
de la création
parce que
comment
Dieu pourrait créer
le monde
dans six jours
il ne faut pas
choquer
sur beaucoup d'aspects
il ne faut pas choquer
parce qu'à un moment
le non-croyant
ne comprendrait pas
quand nous sommes déjà
en train
de venir
avec ce genre
de choses
c'est la même chose
que la parole de Dieu
nous dit dans
Ézéchiel 14
au verset 22
ils viennent avec leurs idoles
dans le cœur
ils viennent te consulter
ils viennent consulter
l'éternel
mais ils viennent avec leurs idoles
dans le cœur
il y a des moments
je suis
je suis totalement effaré
de voir ce que je
quand je vais sur YouTube
et je regarde
l'état des églises en Afrique
je prie vraiment
je ne pense même pas
qu'on puisse appeler ça
des églises
soit disant
ou c'est vraiment
une redéfinition
selon les envies charnelles
il n'y a rien de biblique
à un moment
on se demande
si vraiment
je crois que ce livre
sert juste
à pouvoir utiliser
pour le moment
des offrandes
quand il faut
forcer les personnes
à donner
des offrandes
sinon tout le reste
c'est vraiment
quelque chose
qui sort de l'imagination
des personnes
et ce sont des personnes
qui se donnent
le nom de juifs
Paul disait
à ce sujet
il va dire un moment
dans ce sens
et vous voyez
ce que Paul dit
c'est ce que nous
pouvons retrouver
dans Ézéchiel
c'est ce que nous
pouvons aussi retrouver
pour nous
toi qui te donnes
le nom de juif
toi qui te reposes
sur la loi
donc c'est le principe
un moment
de vouloir se sauver
par les propres oeuvres
un moment
on va redéfinir
l'église
et dans les efforts
ce sera un moment
que le salut
doit être acquis
par les efforts
que tu auras fait
à l'église
par telle ou telle chose
ou par le fait même
de ne pas méditer
la parole
il faut juste
que tu acceptes
la Bible
et que tu ne te compliques
pas trop
la théologie
va t'éloigner
de Dieu
et donc
on redéfinit
nos critères
de salut
toi qui te donnes
le nom de juif
qui te reposes
sur la loi
qui te glorifie
de Dieu
qui connaît
sa volonté
qui apprécie
la différence
des choses
étant instruit
par la loi
toi qui te flatte
d'être le conducteur
des aveugles
la lumière
de ceux
qui sont dans
les ténèbres
le docteur
des insensés
le maître
des ignorants
parce que tu as
dans la loi
la règle
de la science
et de la vérité
toi donc
qui enseignes
les autres
tu ne t'enseignes
pas toi-même
toi qui prêches
de ne pas dérober
tu dérobes
toi qui dis
de ne pas commettre
d'adultère
tu commets
l'adultère
toi qui as
en abomination
les idoles
tu commets
des sacrilèges
toi qui te fais
une gloire
de la loi
tu déshonores
Dieu
par la transgression
de la loi
car le nom de Dieu
est à cause de vous
blasphémé
parmi les païens
comme cela est écrit
encore une fois
Paul parle
de sa génération
mais c'était
la même chose
que Dieu
était en train
de reprocher
aux juifs
au temps
d'Ézéchiel
c'est la même chose
que Dieu
peut reprocher
à une génération
à un moment
qui va se considérer
comme étant sauvée
mais qui est en train
de redéfinir
comment elle doit
adorer Dieu
des personnes
qui vont se dire
sauvées
mais qui vont trouver
normal de pécher
mais qui vont dire
à un moment
ne pêche pas
qui vont trouver
normal d'être
dans l'adultère
mais qui ouvertement
diront de ne pas
être dans l'adultère
le problème des juifs
à un moment
c'était de dire
qu'ils avaient
Dieu comme seul Dieu
de dire
qu'ils avaient
en abomination
les idoles
mais pourtant
ils portaient
des idoles
dans leur cœur
la leçon
que Dieu nous donne
au travers
de ça
et où il montrait
cette haine
et il justifiait
donc le jugement
où Dieu va montrer
un moment
que cette idolâtrie
d'Israël
a conduit
au jugement
à ces jugements
difficiles
qui sont arrivés
la leçon
que Dieu nous enseigne
au travers
de ce passage
donc de
tu as souillé
mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles
et toutes tes abominations
bien sûr
nous pouvons
nous pouvons lire
ce passage
que je viens de lire
dans Romains 2
d'ailleurs
Romains 2
verset 17 à 24
nous pouvons lire
et même trouver
un moment
à certains moments
de notre vie
et voir un moment
qu'il y a une forme
d'hypocrisie
dans notre vie
il peut arriver
un moment
que je vais
enseigner des choses
et ne pas vivre
cette vérité
et là encore
notre frère Loïc
l'a rappelé
un moment
est-ce que nous sommes
en train
d'encourager
les personnes
à la citoyenneté céleste
alors que nous sommes
en train de vivre
avec une soif
de posséder
c'est un peu
souvent l'ambiguïté
du ministère
de la prospérité
d'encourager
des personnes
à la richesse
qui ne sont jamais riches
mais toi par contre
qui est le pasteur
tu continues
à grandir
dans la richesse
matérielle
bien sûr
nous en tant que croyants
lorsque nous lisons
un passage
lorsque nous
voyons ce passage
d'Ézéchel
qui dit
à un moment
tu as souillé
mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles
tes abominations
nous devons aussi
nous arrêter
pour voir aussi
à un moment
est-ce que
quand je viens
dans la présence
de Dieu
je suis en train
de porter des idoles
notre frère Paul
nous disait aussi
une vérité
il disait à un moment
une des choses
du croyant
où nous avons
toujours besoin
de cet examen
c'est de voir
comment le Saint-Esprit
a déjà travaillé
dans notre cœur
mais aussi
de voir le besoin
que cette œuvre
est toujours aussi
en continuité
parce qu'à un moment
nous allons enlever
une idole
mais nous allons voir
à un moment
le cœur
c'est comme
s'il y avait
plein de petits trous
il y a plein de choses
à retirer chaque fois
la parole de Dieu
prend le sens
de l'esprit
qui laboure
la terre
et qui sème
et donc quand on parle
de labourer
le principe de labourer
je parle parce que
maintenant souvent
avec les gens de la ville
il y a des gens
qui connaissent même plus
ce que c'est les champs
quand on laboure
avant de planter
on laboure d'abord
on enlève les mauvaises plantes
tout ça
et quand on a labouré
tourné la terre
là on peut semer les graines
voilà
ça c'était
la leçon
voilà
mais la parole de Dieu
prend ce sens
pour nous montrer aussi
comment Dieu travaille
dans notre cœur
Dieu laboure nos cœurs
il arrache les idoles
et il sème
le fruit de l'esprit
avec ses différentes facettes
et donc nous pouvons
en tant que croyants
nous devons toujours
examiner nos cœurs
et voir ce qui pourrait
constituer des idoles
voir des choses
qui pourraient nous amener
à des cœurs partagés
mais la disposition
d'un cœur régénéré
parce que ce que Paul met
l'accent que Paul met
c'est de parler de personnes
qui ne veulent même pas
prendre conscience
d'un péché
ce sont des personnes
qui trouvent normal
cette pratique
de pécher
mais sous couvert
de la religion
ou de se présenter
comme étant parfait
de vouloir
se justifier
par des œuvres
c'est-à-dire que
là où la conscience
va les condamner
ils savent
à un moment
qu'ils sont dans le péché
voilà pourquoi
ils se rendent dimanche
à l'église
pour essayer de trouver
un peu de la consolation
et samedi prochain
ce sera la boîte
de nuit
et puis dimanche
la consolation
à l'église
pour essayer de trouver
un peu de paix
mais nous
en tant que croyants
avec la disposition
d'un cœur régénéré
ce sera toujours
de nous laisser
corriger par le Seigneur
et de tendre à faire
ce qui honore Dieu
plutôt que les envies
pécheresses
de notre être
et toujours sur cet aspect
de la souillure du sanctuaire
je pense
c'est bien aussi
de laisser
sur quelques aspects
aussi
on finira sur ce point
donc toujours
sur ce point
de la souillure du sanctuaire
et de voir
concrètement pour nous
qu'est-ce que Dieu
peut nous dire
lorsqu'il est en train
de dénoncer
cette apostasie
cette idolâtrie
du peuple d'Israël
chacun de nous
dès le moment
où nous avons eu
nos cœurs régénérés
le Saint-Esprit
est venu habiter
et d'ailleurs
l'une des plus belles
promesses de la Bible
nous la trouvons
au moment où Adam et Ève
ont péché
et Dieu leur fait déjà
la promesse
de tout restaurer
et cette promesse
est encore plus accentuée
quand vous lisez
Ézéchiel
où Dieu parle
de nous enlever
ce cœur de pierre
pour nous donner
un cœur de chair
un cœur
parce que le problème
d'Israël
à un moment
c'était un cœur
la loi était extérieure
la loi n'était pas en eux
et ils avaient du mal
à un moment
à suivre cette loi
mais la promesse
que Dieu fait
dans Ézéchiel
c'est que finalement
il va inscrire
cette loi dans nos cœurs
et nous allons vivre
en fonction
de la présence
de cette loi
dans nos cœurs
donc à cause
de la loi de Dieu
dans nos cœurs
chacun de nous
pour nous qui sommes régénérés
nous sommes devenus
le temple du Saint-Esprit
et comment chacun de nous
nous devons prendre conscience
de ne pas être en train
de souiller le sanctuaire
de l'éternel
que nous sommes
il y a cet aspect
en plusieurs étages
on va dire
souiller le sanctuaire
que nous sommes
parce que chacun de nous
en tant que croyants
le Saint-Esprit
habite en nous
mais nous sommes
un corps
ici à Eubène déjà
où le Saint-Esprit
habite
l'Église
l'ensemble
des croyants en France
nous sommes un corps
dans lequel
le Saint-Esprit
habite
mais déjà
dans une échelle
individuelle
comment nous pouvons
réfléchir
à cet aspect
de ne pas être
en train de souiller
le sanctuaire
de l'éternel
Paul nous donne
encore un aperçu
aussi là-dessus
dans Romains 12
Romains 12
des versets 1 à 2
dans Romains 12
verset 1
Paul nous encourage
à offrir nos corps
comme des sacrifices
vivants
sains
agréables à Dieu
il dit
ce qui sera
de notre part
un culte raisonnable
le sacrifice
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
est ultime
il est ultime
aujourd'hui
si nous vivons
nous vivons
par le principe
d'être sauvés
par la grâce de Dieu
il n'y a rien
et c'est ça aussi
que Dieu voulait souligner
Israël avait besoin
de comprendre
que lorsqu'ils apportaient
leurs offrandes
il n'y avait rien
par lequel ils pouvaient
trouver le plaisir
Dieu
il y avait un enseignement
didactique
ils sacrifiaient
les animaux
en attendant
la venue du Messie
et pour ceux
qui considéraient
à un moment
que le sacrifice
des animaux
était un sacrifice
permanent
qui leur permettait
de se sentir justifiés
c'est parce qu'ils avaient
oublié
les promesses
que l'éternel avait faites
et c'est là où il dit
à un moment
je t'avais placé
au milieu des nations
pour être une lumière
le principe
c'est qu'Israël
devait rappeler aux nations
que ces nations
qui vivaient
les conséquences
du péché
de la chute
un jour connaîtraient
la rédemption
par Dieu
qui allait être
homme
et qui allait
restaurer
toute chose
mais lorsque
Israël
va détourner
la compréhension
du sacrifice
où ils vont
à un moment
comprendre
que le sacrifice
des animaux
est suffisant
pour pardonner
leur péché
ou leurs efforts
sont suffisants
pour pardonner
leur péché
ils ont oublié
le Christ
le sacrifice
du Seigneur
Jésus Christ
est ultime
et donc
quand Paul nous parle
d'offrir nos corps
comme des sacrifices
vivants
sains et agréables
il n'est pas en train
de nous demander
de faire des efforts
pour gagner encore
le salut de Dieu
il est en train
de nous dire
à un moment
que par rapport
au sacrifice
de Christ
qui est parfait
et qui a rendu
obsolète
toutes sortes
de sacrifices
notre seule réponse
sera d'offrir
tout ce que nous sommes
entièrement au Seigneur
là il ne s'agit plus
d'offrir des animaux
il ne s'agit même pas
d'offrir une voiture
là encore
c'est en phase
le peuple d'Israël
le problème
c'est qu'un moment
ils voulaient garder
leurs idoles
dans le coeur
et ils se disaient
qu'ils pouvaient
apaiser Dieu
par les sacrifices
qu'ils faisaient
non
le premier sacrifice
que nous faisons
c'est d'abord
que tout notre être
esprit, âme et corps
soit donné au Seigneur
et alors Dieu
va agréer nos sacrifices
Paul le rappelle aussi
dans ce passage
où il va dire un moment
en parlant des frères
qu'il avait donné
il a dit
ils se sont d'abord
donnés au Seigneur
et ensuite à nous
et donc
pour nous
nous comprenons
à un moment
qu'il n'y a rien
que nous puissions faire
maintenant
pour gagner le salut
de Dieu
c'est la grâce de Dieu
qui vit en nous
et notre seule réponse
ce sera que notre corps
devienne un instrument
de justice pour Dieu
mais si notre corps
et tout ce qu'il est
n'est pas un instrument
de justice pour Dieu
alors
nous sommes en train
de faire
ce que Dieu
a dénoncé
avec Ézéchiel
nous sommes en train
de souiller le sanctuaire
en nous conformant au monde
qu'est-ce que c'est
la conformité au monde
d'ailleurs même
souvent on va voir
souvent
là quand j'étais en train
de préparer
c'était
assez drôle pour moi
de voir que
ce que Dieu nous demande
pour que notre coeur
ne se conforme pas au monde
mais que nous soyons
renouvelés
dans notre intelligence
est quand même
assez simple
mais aujourd'hui
vous pouvez voir
des personnes
qui vont vous partager
plusieurs pratiques
plusieurs choses à faire
pour pouvoir
ne pas se conformer
au monde
mais
avant de venir
sur ce point
1 Jean 2
verset 15 à 16
quand on parle
de qu'est-ce que c'est
de se conformer au monde
Jean nous dit
n'aimez point le monde
ni les choses
qui sont dans le monde
si quelqu'un aime le monde
l'amour du Père
n'est point en lui
donc vous voyez
tout vient d'abord
d'une question du coeur
le problème d'Israël
quand
au niveau des équels
c'est que déjà
leur coeur
n'était pas
tourné vers l'éternel
à partir du moment
leur sacrifice
ne pouvait pas
être agréé par Dieu
et là encore
si notre coeur
même si nous pouvons
offrir
visiblement
une offrande à Dieu
par notre présence occulte
ou par beaucoup
d'autres choses
visibles aux yeux
des hommes
si notre coeur
n'est pas dans
cette disposition
à avoir
l'amour du Père
alors
nous sommes
en train
de souiller
le sanctuaire
n'aimez point le monde
ni les choses
qui sont dans le monde
si quelqu'un aime le monde
l'amour du Père
n'est pas en lui
car tout ce qui est
dans le monde
la convoitise de la chair
la convoitise des yeux
et l'orgueil de la vie
ne vient
point du Père
mais vient du monde
et le monde passe
et sa convoitise aussi
mais celui qui fait
la volonté de Dieu
demeure éternellement
la parole de Dieu
définit la conformité
ou l'amour du monde
par la convoitise
de la chair
donc là
je vous invite
à pouvoir
réécouter les prédications
de notre frère David
sur Galate
lorsqu'il aborde
un moment
les fruits de la chair
on va avoir
les excès de table
le sexe
qui aujourd'hui
est un élément
déterminant
pour une génération
tout ce qui peut satisfaire
nos cinq sens
sans honorer Dieu
c'est la convoitise
de la chair
la convoitise des yeux
la soif de posséder
la convoitise
la jalousie
il parle de l'orgueil
de la vie
l'orgueil de la vie
ça peut être dû
aux richesses
aux ambitions
qu'on peut avoir
à un moment
ces ambitions
qui vont
nous amener
à vouloir
nous conformer
au monde
à souiller
le sanctuaire
de Dieu
parce qu'à un moment
nous allons
nous allons faire
de nos richesses
de nos ambitions
des réalisations
de nos vies
des idoles
qui prennent
le trône
la place de Dieu
sur cet aspect
c'est intéressant
aussi
un des enseignements
que nous avons eu
lors des matinées
pastorales
c'était de nous rappeler
à un moment
que Dieu ne rentre
dans aucune
de ces catégories
nous ne pouvons
comparer Dieu
à rien
on ne peut pas
comparer Dieu
à nos réalisations
à nos ambitions
on ne peut comparer
Dieu à rien
la place de Dieu
est une place
qui est unique
mais vous voyez
là où nous arrivons
au niveau du péché
c'est un moment
c'est d'arriver
la méchanceté
du coeur humain
nous arrivons
à un moment
à ce que
toutes ces choses
cet orgueil
de la vie
ces convoitises
et autres
puissent combattre
à cette place
qui doit être unique
pour Dieu
n'aimons pas
le monde
mais laissons-nous
transformer
par le renouvellement
de l'intelligence
c'est ce que Paul va dire
afin que nous discernions
quelle est la volonté
de Dieu
ce qui est bon
agréable
et parfait
et sur cet aspect
de nous conformer
de ne pas souiller
le sanctuaire
en nous conformant
au monde
là encore
de même
que lorsque nous parlons
d'une génération
perverse
corrompue
dans Romains
semblable à celle
d'Ézéchiel
semblable à la nôtre
nous voyons aussi
que la parole
de Dieu
demeure
et la même
elle demeure
éternellement
là où des personnes
se permettent
d'ajouter
autre chose
de redéfinir
que cette parole
est ancienne
tout ce que Dieu
tout ce qui était
contre
ce que nous venons
de dire
c'est la même chose
dans Ézéchiel
que Ézéchiel va recommander
c'est la même chose
que Paul va recommander
que nous devons
recommander
dans notre génération
qu'est-ce que nous
dit la parole
pour éviter
de laisser notre cœur
être un sanctuaire
souillé
c'est
que la parole
de Dieu
soit dans chaque
aspect de notre vie
nous devons écouter
la parole de Dieu
avec un cœur
honnête
et bon
chaque fois
que la parole
de Dieu
le problème
des Israélites
avec Ézéchiel
avec Jérémie
c'est que même
quand ils étaient
conscients de leur péché
et que Dieu
pointait leur péché
ils avaient décidé
de ne pas se repentir
la Bible
le Seigneur dit
à un moment
regarde
ils viennent te consulter
ils viennent me consulter
mais ils portent
leurs idoles
dans leur cœur
donc en fait
ils venaient
consulter Ézéchiel
mais ils avaient
déjà décidé
qu'ils ne changeraient pas
mais notre disposition
et notre prière
chaque fois
que nous avons l'occasion
d'écouter la parole
de Dieu
chaque fois
que nous avons l'occasion
d'écouter Dieu
c'est de venir
avec un cœur honnête
c'est de prier
pour nous laisser
confronter par la parole
c'est de prier
pour que là
où il y a des choses
où nous avons besoin
d'être corrigés
même nous sommes conscients
d'avoir besoin
d'être corrigés
par la parole
que nous laissions
la parole de Dieu
nous éclairer là-dessus
un cœur
honnête et bon
bon
dans l'aspect
de considérer
que la parole
de Dieu
est juste
le souci
lorsqu'on va
venir avec nos idoles
c'est que nous considérons
déjà que la parole
de Dieu
n'est pas suffisante
le principe des idoles
c'est le principe
d'un cœur partagé
nous considérons
à un moment
que la parole
de Dieu
n'est pas suffisante
il faut que nous
la comblions
avec certaines choses
il faut soit
qu'on enlève
certaines parties
de la parole
qui ne nous conviennent pas
il faut soit
que nous ajoutions
des choses
à la parole de Dieu
pour que ça puisse
convenir à notre cœur
mais lorsque nous venons
avec un cœur
honnête et bon
c'est d'accepter
la parole
comme étant suffisante
c'est d'accepter
la parole
comme étant
centrale
et suffisante
l'autre aspect
un autre aspect
qui nous permet
de ne pas souiller
le sanctuaire
de ne pas nous conformer
au monde
c'est de lire
la parole de Dieu
abondamment
à un moment
pendant la conférence
j'ai eu des témoignages
de quelques saints aussi
je comprends
ce que je suis
en principal jugement
je peux comprendre
moi-même
j'ai cette situation
de souvent
on a beaucoup de livres
on reçoit beaucoup de livres
lors de la conférence
déjà c'est pour dire
il faut les lire
si déjà
tu as eu beaucoup
de ces livres
et que tu n'as pas encore lu
depuis 4-5 ans
là il y a un problème
mais
nous recevons beaucoup
et certains vont dire
à un moment
j'ai du mal
à lire certains livres
parce que ça ne me parle pas
la chose qu'il y a
c'est que
nous devons discipliner
nos cœurs
par rapport à la bénédiction
de Dieu
le conseil de Dieu
il est entier
quand Paul parlait
à un moment
c'est d'annoncer
tout le conseil de Dieu
nous avons besoin
par rapport à tous ces livres
qui peuvent nous parler
du conseil de Dieu
de façon générale
nous avons besoin
de cultiver ça
mais ce que je veux dire
en emphase
c'est bien
de lire les livres
mais c'est bien
de lire le livre
le livre le plus important
ne commence pas ta journée
avec des dévotions
d'un autre livre
si tu n'as pas lu la Bible
la parole de Dieu
doit toujours être
la première chose
avec laquelle
nous ouvrons les yeux
et même peut-être
avec laquelle
avant de nous endormir
nous sommes en train
de fermer les yeux
nous devons la lire
abondamment
je sais
un peu comme
les israélites
lorsque j'arrive
à la partie
des livres
du Pentateuch
c'est drôle
je traverse le désert
aussi avec eux
c'est très dur
à lire
j'ai mon désert
aussi que je traverse
quand je lis
Lévitique
Deutéronome
c'est très difficile
mais c'est nécessaire
et si nous voulons
comprendre
l'oeuvre parfaite
de Christ
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre
l'oeuvre parfaite
du Christ glorifié
si nous ne lisons
pas les livres
du Pentateuch
donc si aujourd'hui
tu es là
et que tu n'as jamais lu
des livres
de l'Ancien Testament
et que tu as
comment dire
entre guillemets
tu es un vieux croyant
je t'invite à corriger cela
tu dois les lire
nous devons lire
la parole abondamment
nous devons étudier
cette même parole
abondamment
c'est comme ça
que nous préservons
notre coeur
des souillots du monde
nous devons étudier
cette parole
il ne suffit pas
un moment de la lire
il est aussi nécessaire
vous voyez tout ce que
je suis en train de vous donner
je pourrais vous donner
des références bibliques
à tout ce que je suis en train
de dire
quand on parle
de confronter nos coeurs
avec des coeurs honnêtes
et bons
de lire la parole
abondamment
de l'étudier
cette même parole
la parole de Dieu
regorge
de plusieurs références
là dessus
mais aujourd'hui
nous allons trouver
des chrétiens
qui vont dire
un moment
moi je n'étudie pas
la parole
ce sont des choses
trop compliquées
lorsque les gens
commencent à étudier
la parole
ça apporte des divisions
ça apporte un manque
d'unité
mais la seule unité
que nous pouvons avoir
se base sur la parole
si à un moment
il y a des choses
qui sont claires
dans la parole
et que certains
d'entre nous ne font pas
nous ne pourrons pas
parler d'unité
l'unité se trouve
à cause de ce qui est
contenu dans cette parole
et à laquelle
nous nous soumettons
donc nous devons étudier
cette même parole
mais nous ne devons pas
seulement nous arrêter
à l'étudier
nous devons la mémoriser
nous devons mémoriser
la parole de Dieu
le problème d'Israël
si vous vous souvenez
un moment
quand je parlais
de cet aspect
même pour Ézéchiel
c'est que Israël
avait oublié
lorsqu'ils arrivent
dans cette situation
il y a très peu
qui savent
pourquoi ils sont là
Daniel le sait
Daniel va dire
un moment
quand il fait sa prière
d'intercession
il va dire
pardonne-nous
nos iniquités
l'iniquité de nos pères
et celle de nos pères
parce que Daniel sait
que s'ils ont été déportés
ce n'est pas par accident
s'ils ont été déportés
c'est parce qu'ils avaient péché
et ce depuis plusieurs siècles
mais d'autres ne le savaient pas
pourquoi d'autres ne le savaient pas
c'est parce que vous allez même
retrouver des épisodes
où la parole de Dieu
avait complètement disparu
à un moment
ils ont même
l'heureuse grâce
sous le règne de Josias
de retrouver
une copie
de la parole
de l'éternel
mais parce qu'ils avaient oublié
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
mémorisé cette parole
ils ne pouvaient pas savoir
ce que Dieu attendait d'eux
et nous avons besoin
de mémoriser la parole
notamment pour les moments
difficiles de notre vie
plusieurs fois
lorsque nous allons traverser
des moments difficiles
des épreuves
des questions
nous devons
qu'est-ce que nous devons faire
où est-ce que nous devons aller
nous allons commencer
à paniquer
à chercher
même à chercher
la présence des hommes
à vouloir écouter des hommes
à chercher
à écouter des pasteurs
il faut que le pasteur me dise
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
je ne sais pas si je dois aller
au Canada ou pas
il faut que le pasteur
ce soit
c'est le pasteur qui va me dire
si je vais au Canada ou pas
ça c'est contraire
à ce que la parole de Dieu
nous dit
la parole de Dieu
nous dit à un moment
que la loi
l'esprit de Dieu
est dans le coeur
de chacun de nous
et si je dois
à un moment
confronter mes choix
je dois aller vers
ce que dit la parole de Dieu
là encore
une chose
le frère
Paul Washer
nous disait à un moment
que
une des choses
aujourd'hui
à un moment
où il encourage
beaucoup les personnes
c'est que
pour briser cette dépendance
au pasteur
où c'est le pasteur
qui doit lire la Bible
et nous on ne lit pas la Bible
et puis c'est lui
qui doit découvrir
le bon passage
pour m'envoyer au Canada
ou autre
il disait
maintenant
quand quelqu'un
vient lui poser un problème
il lui dit
va lire ta Bible
va voir
qu'est-ce que la parole de Dieu
te dit là-dessus
et maintenant
si tu as encore des difficultés
pour comprendre
tu viens
je vais
on va voir maintenant
pour voir si
tu es bien en train de suivre
ce que
les procédés
pour interpréter
ce que la parole de Dieu dit
on peut recevoir
des révélations
mais ça peut être la chair
ça peut être Satan
nous avons besoin
de toujours avoir
les bons outils
pour savoir
ce que dit
la parole de Dieu
ce que Dieu dit
pour nos vies
et si nous ne mémorisons
pas la parole
mais que nous espérons
que c'est le pasteur
qui va la mémoriser
pour nous
et qui va la sortir
à un moment
où nous sommes désespérés
nous allons être encore
dans beaucoup plus
de problèmes
et enfin
un dernier point
pour ne pas
souiller
ce sanctuaire
que nous sommes
et éviter
cette conformité
au monde
nous avons besoin
de méditer la parole
c'est très différent
d'étudier la parole
le fait
de méditer la parole
c'est le fait
de prendre le temps
de comprendre
les choses
c'est le fait
de prendre le temps
pour que ces vérités
que je suis en train
de lire dans la parole
soient des vérités
qui sont en train
d'être réelles pour moi
la première vérité
déjà quand je vais lire
la parole
c'est de comprendre
qu'est-ce que la parole
m'enseigne au sujet
de Christ
et qu'est-ce qu'elle
m'enseigne au travers
de l'œuvre merveilleuse
que Christ a fait pour moi
et ensuite
je pourrais aussi
comprendre
des applications pratiques
pour moi
par rapport à cette parole
voyez on a un verset
aujourd'hui
on va d'abord
ouvrir la Bible
il faut d'abord
que Dieu nous parle
par rapport à nos envies
par rapport à nos besoins
et si on a assez de temps
on pourra méditer
pour l'œuvre de Christ
d'ailleurs certains
trouvent même ça
très ennuyant
donc ils n'arrivent
même pas à cette étape
mais notre première priorité
quand nous lisons la parole
qu'est-ce que Dieu
nous enseigne
sur ce que notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ a accompli
de merveilleux pour nous
et qu'est-ce qu'il nous enseigne
de façon pratique
en fonction de cette œuvre
accomplie par Christ
et tous ces points
que je viens de citer
ne doivent avoir
qu'un seul but
nous allons écouter
la parole de Dieu
nous allons lire
des livres
que Dieu a pu inspirer
par son esprit
à des frères
pour mieux nous expliquer
la Bible
nous allons étudier
cette parole
nous allons la mémoriser
nous allons la méditer
mais avec un seul but
c'est que
la réalité du Christ glorifié
soit toujours plus grandissante
soit toujours plus soutenue
dans nos vies
notre prière
chaque jour doit être
que Christ soit en train
de croître en nous
tandis que nous soyons
en train de diminuer
et je finis avec ce passage
ce que Ephésiens 3
16 19 nous dit
et je pense
c'est aussi comme une prière
pour chacun de nous
dans ce sens
par rapport à tout ce que
nous avons écouté
que la réalité du Christ
glorifié
soit toujours plus grandissante
soit toujours plus soutenue
dans nos vies
afin que selon la richesse
de sa gloire
Christ nous donne
d'être puissamment fortifié
par son esprit
dans notre âme intérieure
notre âme intérieure
a d'avoir besoin
d'être purifié
d'être sanctifié
et alors
notre sacrifice sera agréable
en sorte qu'il y habite
en sorte que Christ
habite dans nos cœurs
par la foi
ainsi enraciné
et fondé dans son amour
nous prendrons encore
plus conscience
de l'amour de Christ
qui surpasse
toute connaissance
en sorte que nous soyons
remplis jusqu'à toute
la plénitude de Dieu
pour notre sanctification
pour notre témoignage